Professor Yan lacun is a French computer
scientist known for his pioneering work
on convolutional neural networks optical
character recognition and computer
vision
he's a silver professor at New York
University and vice president and chief
AI scientist at meta alongside Joshua
benzio and Jeffrey Hinton he was awarded
the 2018 touring award for their work on
deep learning earning himself the
nickname as one of the Godfathers of
deep learning
enjoy lovely to see you in person so we
had a great conversation with ishan and
Randall earlier about the um the
self-supervised uh paper and also the
data augmentation paper right I just
wondered if if you had any thoughts on
the papers
well
um so Randall has
four papers at equal authored at nerves
which is kind of uh
uh very impressive uh all of them kind
of saw my theoretical but all of them
really having an Insight that's really
important really interesting uh one of
the one that was presented today is
actually on uh unitary uh neuronet so
these are neural Nets where the weight
Matrix is forced to be a unitary Matrix
basically a form of rotation in complex
space and that has some advantages
because it solves some technical issue
with either exploding of any ingredient
and also it can be seen as sort of a
model of quantum computation in fact the
main author bobaki is a quantum computer
yeah a student at 19 with CES Floyd who
was the the last author of the paper is
you know one of the best known people in
Quantum Computing so that's a very
interesting paper it's uh it makes the
idea of uh training unitary Matrix is
efficient then there is the paper also
that was presented today on some
analytical
study of what data augmentation does for
you right so you can you can take an
image
and you can uh
you know transform it in various ways
and the number of different ways in
which you can transform an image you
know is kind of quite infinite it turns
out you should take the limit to
Infinity you get some sort of formula
that you can actually solve and so
basically you kind of see the effect of
uh that would be equivalent to having an
infinite number of data augmentation for
a single sample yeah that reminded me of
the kernel trick actually it's a similar
kind of content actually the thing that
reminds me of is some work that uh
Patricia Mark did at Bell Labs many many
years ago yeah uh which I was a
co-author as well called uh tension
propagation and tangent distance so this
is really kind of closely related to to
that but it's interesting to kind of see
those ideas coming back to the four
and then uh
uh another really interesting paper uh
from Randall is about uh
you know basically when you do
self-supervised running we did
augmentation you have a large number of
training samples and then you distort
them and you view distorted version of
the same sample as being similar or
identical yes and then different samples
to be dissimilar and you can view this
uh conceptually as a big graph of
similarity where you collect all the
samples and their augmentations yes and
then you build a giant gigantic Matrix
if you want where you put you know one
if there are similar zero if they're not
um and what Randall figured out is that
what's important are the spectral
property of this Matrix so basically the
second Vector second values
in relation to
the the spectral properties of a a
similar Matrix that would correspond to
the for example a a supervised test Okay
so
the the
self-supervised task surrogate task if
you want is going to help
to solve the supervised staff to the
extent that those two matrices have
matching uh spectral properties you
could you could say this indeed I had a
question about that so um in a way the
the um creating that adjacency Matrix is
is a hypothetical to tell us about the
representational capacity of
self-supervised embeddings but what does
it mean for self-supervised learning in
general if if it feels like we need to
have the class labels back to create
that adjacency metrics well so um you
don't have it right I mean you make a
processor you don't have it in the
training phase of course but what what
the what the result tells you is uh
the surrogate tasks that consists in
distorting your images or whatever it is
that you use yeah in the self-supervised
phase
it will help the final uh task to the
extent that the the eigenvectors of the
two matrices are have some overlap
interesting interesting and how do you
think that because in in the dno paper
um Matilda had had a diagram which was
speaking about the pointillistic nature
of supervised learning and open AI
recently released a bit of a
um a slightly combative paper whisper
where they were kind of saying well
supervised representations are very
robust out of distribution so I just
wondered what's your current thinking
around the robustness of cell supervised
representation
so I think uh
ultimately I think self-supervised
methods that use multiple criteria
are going to be the the main method to
try and to free train neural Nets before
we train them for a particular task
right
um and the the trick is I mean the big
question is uh can you build those
surrogate tasks without requiring
expensive uh manual labeling and this is
what the documentation does it's just a
way of generating labeled data if you
want yeah uh which is not really labels
but you know it's kind of similar yeah
um without requiring human uh
intervention so so you know are there
other tricks you can use that are
similar to that
that would drive the system to learn the
right things yeah and um
uh the answer is not clear at this point
but um but like you know the ideas I've
been floating around for a long time
including in computational Neuroscience
like
a slow feature analysis for example so
the hypothesis that the representation
of uh two frames in a video
that are successive or nearby should
basically be similar because they
probably contain the same objects
perhaps in slightly different positions
um but the essential content is the same
so if you have a Criterion that tends to
produce similar representations for
nearby frames then you probably have uh
you know
a good Criterion for extracting kind of
relevant features about the world
um I'm sort of becoming a much bigger
fan of prediction
so observing uh temporal or spatial
evolution of a phenomenon and then
training assistant to predict I'm a huge
fan of your paper by the way the path to
autonomous AI right right so that all
that's all based on this idea right
prediction and to some extent all the
papers that we're seeing right now on uh
cell super versioning based on masking
yeah are essentially versions of this so
right so you take an image a video a
piece of audio or something and then you
have a corrupted version of it that
where some pieces are missing yeah that
you show to a network and then uh and
then you try to get this network to
predict the parts that I'm missing
essentially yeah so you can do this in a
generative way which is what Mass Proto
encoders and you know singletoners are
doing that works really well in NLP
it doesn't work so well in images I mean
there's Nae which comes out of there
which works okay but it's difficult to
scale uh it doesn't it doesn't produce
like really good uh
features you have to like fine tune
um for for the features to be good uh
but uh but it has this idea that you
know you you mask a piece and and you
you predict the part that is not not
mask right yes now would it become much
more fond of now is is not generating
models but what's called John 10 meeting
architecture so all the best
SSL method for images using use joint
embedding yeah yeah you you have
internet don't contrast it well so then
you can use either contrasting or
non-contacting method to train them but
I'm advocating for non-contractive
because I think contrasting methods
don't scare very well could I could I
touch on that because Rando and I were
joking about the uh not not quite
rivalry with with you and Jeff going
back many many years and um because
because I think even to this day you
said in your in your japa paper that the
non-contrasted methods are a way of
shrink wrapping the latent space around
around that's right and I just wondered
has your thinking changed about that and
and
what would you say to people who who
still think that it's possible to
achieve good results or contrastive uh
well um I mean you do get good results
from Contracting methods it's just that
you get results and we've shown this in
the number of other papers that the the
the part of the space that is occupied
by the representation is relatively low
Dimension yeah so it's kind of a
dimensional collapse yeah that's what we
call it actually so you try and
Contracting methods like seem clear for
example and the the type of
representations that you get spans a
relatively low dimensional set space of
the representation space and so um
so that tells you that when you want to
kind of push things to be different and
you are in a high-dimensional space
you're kind of you know the number of uh
negative pairs that you need grows
exponentially with the dimension of the
space essentially yes yes
um and so that that's what makes me kind
of dubious but then
um
uh but then we have a the people on
archives uh Randall the score as well
actually we're
um uh this is a paper by uh container
who is a PhD student with me in Paris
and that shows that there is actually
some sort of Duality between potassium
and non-contracting methods
um in uh contrasting method
what you're trying to do is make sure
that the representations produced by the
system for different samples in a batch
are all different right so you take a
matrix of representations they're trying
to make the rows of that Matrix
different yeah non-contracting methods
are actually contrastive but they are
contrastive in the other dimensions
right so they're trying to make all the
variables of a representation different
and uh so one deals with governance
Matrix which is z times Z transpose and
the other one is z transpose Z and those
two matrices are the same eigenvectors
the same eigenvalue so uh or have you
know Common properties and so there is a
duality between those two methods which
seems to invalidate the argument I have
that uh so you know we're still kind of
trying to to go through this and try to
really understand what the yes the story
is there but but uh ultimately I think
non-contesting methods are another way
to go fascinating just quickly finishing
on Japan so I was speaking with sep just
a little while ago and and he also um
agrees with you I think which is that
the ability to model phenomena at
multiple levels of abstraction or
description is really really important
right and and also you know doing it
with with the joint embedding prediction
architecture on the latent space Also
action space abstractions and time as
well as concept abstraction I was a huge
fan of of that paper it's very very
interesting
um but the other thing of course it did
was introduce uncertainty quantification
as part of the um you know predicting
what what is um you know not observed
from what is observed that's right so
it's it's a bit but I mean one one thing
I did think at the time though is that
it does start to resemble a handcrafted
um cognitive architecture again it is
yeah it is it's a cognitive architecture
well what would Rich Sutton say
oh I don't know what we shouldn't say
you know he's co-author of this paper
reward is enough right I mean I'd love
to get your thoughts on that
well I in in my position paper I say
reward is not enough I know it's not
uh I mean I think actually uh
I think I say this as like a half a joke
but uh
I think the the purpose of
reinforcemental need to should be to
minimize the user reinforcement running
because reinforcement running is so damn
inefficient pardon my French yes so uh
so in fact I think whenever whenever
possible we should be using something
like a model predictive control or
something like that which is way more
efficient like planning okay which is a
sort of more classical AI type approach
yeah
um but which you know systems like uh
like Museum used and some systems that
I've worked on with uh foreign
autonomous driving for you know planning
trajectories and stuff like that and
uh you know there's a lot of work going
back you know quite a long time on on on
planning I think that's frankly this
idea that uh
sort of intelligence system should
optimize an objective by planning a
sequence of actions or a sequence of uh
you know can you text or whatever that
that's what would make those models
controllable
whereas currently they really are not
like you can't it's very hard to control
the language model to do something
particularly other than by feeding it a
huge part which really is a bad way of
specifying your task indeed so uh
uh and then the thing you mentioned is
the ability to represent sort of
hierarchical action plans yes this is
something that no AI systems today can
do yeah and I think it's a super
important problem I don't have a
complete solution for it I just have a
hint of a solution which I present in
that paper but yeah I think that's kind
of a major major uh obstacle to be
interested on reward is enough and I I
think you know there are different ways
of defining intelligence so there's
Behavior there's function you know does
it do planning and reasoning like norvig
would say um there's capability there's
principle which is I think that some of
these folks who think reward is enough
that they have this idea that an
intelligent agent is just taking the
right trajectory of decisions you know
Bayesian optimal decisions if you like
them and I think that's where a lot of
this kind of thinking process stems from
would you agree with that or do you have
a different conception of intelligence
so I think uh
you know there is certainly
okay let's take a simple problem of
classification when you train a
classifier the real function you want to
minimize is classification error but we
will never do this we always come up
with a surrogate objective
uh that we optimize that happens to be
differentiable because number of Errors
is not differentiable right so you
approximate this with cross entropy or
whatever right
um and and then you can do it in descent
and that's the success of deep learning
is to basically say look you know we
can't optimize the supplementary
optimize we can find those other
objectives are just as good and we
optimize those with great in these
methods so reinforcement learning uh is
the application to control
of this this idea that you have an
objective you want to minimize but the
problem is that it's not differentiable
yeah uh you only get this value once in
a while to estimate this gradient you
have to take multiple actions to see you
know a policy gradient basically you
need to kind of see how it varies when
you uh when you change the action so
that you can uh that has find a minimum
and that's a very inefficient way of
optimizing anything that learns so what
you should have is have a surrogate cost
that is a good approximation of the cost
you actually want to minimize but it's
differentiable and if it's
differentiable
then you can use gradient-based methods
to do planning you don't have to learn a
policy you could learn a policy of
course but but and then that becomes
what people call HTML control which has
been around since the 50s uh you know
it's a you're on that version of it if
you want but it's it's the same sort of
overall framework yeah
um that's what you should do whenever
you can I mean the same way nobody ever
trains the neural net using gradient
free methods to minimize specification
error nobody should ever use RL
people should use optimal control we
surrogate costs that are differentiable
that approximate the cost you actually
want to minimize
now of course you know you can't do this
approximation exactly so
once in a while you have to discover
that your surrogate class is not the
right one and then you have to adjust it
and that's RL but but presumably you
would have to use it extremely rarely
right so indeed so again the purpose of
RL research should be to minimize its
use amazing that's a wonderful thing I
don't want to take out too much more of
a time but um I wanted to quickly come
back to Randall so first of all um
Randall is one of the most talented
researchers that that I know of he has
um I I wanted to just get your comments
on what it's like to work with Randall
but also his spline theory of neural
networks I find particularly interesting
particularly interesting and also
um he's recently uh because I guess you
know I mean it all started with your um
extrapolation paper right right and then
we discovered Randall's work as a
byproduct of that and our initial
reading of of Randall's work is that um
you know in respect of of an input
example a neural network can be
represented as an affine transformation
and we were kind of thinking that this
almost reinforces the idea that um
neural networks are locality sensitive
hashing tables and they don't
extrapolate and my conception at the
time was that all of the inductive
priors you know like for example the CNN
what it does is it photocopies the input
data it kind of TR it spreads it out
over the ambient space and then we have
this kind of this polyhedra that capture
all of the photocopies but now Randall
has said well actually in contrast to
decision trees they are extrapolative
because these are continuous regions and
they make very informed they they give
you very informed information about
extrapolative regions that were not seen
during training and that actually
explains a lot of the extrapolation
that's true yeah yeah yeah I mean it's
kind of a similar argument that people
had when comparing you know back in the
old days comparing uh like nearest
neighbor classifiers to linear
classifiers yeah linear classifier you
know puts a boundary on that side of
that boundary it extrapolates you can
think of this forever as nearest
neighbor doesn't yeah uh right he's not
not nearly in the same kind of
um same respect
fantastic and and just a quick comment
on what it's like to work with Randall
oh it's fantastic you know it's very
productive and comes up with lots of uh
theoretical insights and and things like
that and and you know and
you don't need to give him ideas because
he comes up with tons of them but if you
give him one he's going to run with it
also amazing uh yeah no it's a wonderful
tour yeah and it's a pleasure to meet
you it's a pleasure to meet you thank
you so much
so it becomes a constraint optimization
problem and this is the exactly what you
obtain and you reproversion again maps
from the Craig so it's the same loss
function and it's just that it's a
non-parametric regime right yeah okay so
um I'm just taking a little bit of time
to chat with Randall
today's the big day actually you're
doing a poster yes yes first of all
actually so it's going to be warm up for
me but today is a really interesting one
on self-supervised learning uh telling
it to spectral embedding and trying to
understand in a more principal way when
does it work when does it fail and when
can you unite actually those two side of
the same thing fantastic well give us
the the elevators picture of the place
sure so the main idea is that now you
have a ton of different self-supervised
glosses right many different variants
and it's not clear how to navigate this
space right given a new problem new data
set which laws do you want to use and
why and so what we do in this paper is
that we actually tie most of those
verses to known spectral embedding
methods we show that it's exactly the
same laws we have the same optimal
representation you can find things
analytically and prove this already and
from this we can use the rich literature
or spectral embedding to tell you when
in which type of data distribution is
one loss better than the other and what
type of properties of your data those
one laws try to care about compared to
those other losses so by doing this a
very simple bridge then we can get a big
insight into guiding practitioners
basically in which class to use when and
why and so this is the main work of the
contribution and another one is that
through this bridge again which we see
that the main task of cell supervised
learning is to design a good relation
graph basically so if you have a lot of
data points when you define a positive
pair what you say that okay this sample
and this sample are positively related
to each other and this if you look at
your big graph of data points you add a
connection with between those two points
and if you know or to put those
connections correctly then you can
actually learn optimal representations
and for example if you do supervised
training the only thing it means is that
you already know where to put all those
connections because you're the class
labels but you see you have the same
unified Viewpoint for supervised
training SSL and you can try from this
to understand how can you maybe
interpolate between those two regime you
can try to say okay can you do better
ways in finding which pairs are
connected and if you know to do this
efficiently you can for example get rid
of that augmentation altogether to
Define your positive path and so on and
so forth so hopefully this opens a lot
of doors for future War oh that's really
interesting and and if there are
multiple classes then you just add
multiple entries into that so in this
big n by n Matrix and being the number
of sample you have if you have let's say
three classes this just means that you
have three blocks in this big Matrix
connecting all the points from class one
together all the points from class 2
together and all the points of class 3
together so I actually put some
instruction of this in the poster so you
will see that later but you can really
from this unified Viewpoint uh you have
a graph you know same thing in both
cases you can tackle supervised learning
multi-class or not multi-class SSL and
you can see in between what's happening
even semi supervised learning where in
this case you only know some labels for
some of the samples and you already know
the entries of these big graphs these
big metrics for those specific ones and
then the question is okay what do we do
with those other ones and here we have
many methods and one thing you could do
for example from this that you could use
self-supervised learning for those other
guys and we show you can do this
probably basically not just by combining
losses without any guarantee interesting
so um Devil's Advocate from the
perspective of data augmentation that's
a really interesting way to encode more
prior information into the predictive
architecture so yeah what if um I would
suggest that and we we need that prior
information and we're losing it somehow
yeah so that's a good point so if you
add some prior this is good as long as
you know which prior to add right and
one problem with SSL now is that if you
remove some of the data augmentation you
have a big drop in performance and you
have some collapse representation that
appear especially for example Coral
Jitter if you have images and one thing
that you could do if you mix okay
specifying only some of the data
augmentation but also enabling to
discover some other ones from the data
by figuring out how to pair the sumpers
then you can try to have the best of
both swords right and suddenly you can
come up with new materials Naturally by
pairing those points that you could not
come up with just by trying to define a
data augmentation you know in by torch
or whatever and so one method that
already tries to take a step in that
direction is and then clear where
basically so it's an extension of
Sinclair it's really recent I think two
years ago it appears and what they do is
that they look in embedding space and
they look at the nearest neighbor of the
sumper to Define which ones should be
your positive pairs so if you remember
this big n by n can action Matrix what
it says that okay this point I will
figure out which other one is it
connected to based on the nearest
neighbor in embedding space and so you
see this is really a first step toward
the automated Discovery let's say of of
knowledge and because of this now that I
can get through the way of me specifying
the data augmentation pipeline so for
example they can just use random crop so
really not too informative that
argumentation pipelines and naturally
because of the universe Network pairing
you will have Rich enough positive pairs
that you can learn really good
representation reaching state-of-the-art
performance basically so the goal here
is to show why this work why is it
meaningful and to improve this from
first principles amazing and by the way
we're huge fans of the original simply
by Simon kombliff that was one of our
favorite yeah these that we did but
um this also brings me back to we were
discussing yesterday a little bit about
the the history of um you know
contrastive versus non-contrasted
learning you're actually saying that
there is a I mean rivalry is is too
strong a word but there's a bit of a an
interesting background to that with
Hinton and and nakum yes yeah exactly so
yeah right really maybe it's a bit uh a
bit too strong of a world but let's say
uh two different objectives basically uh
that led to those two two big directions
so just in turn so 20 30 years ago I was
trying to use this uh contrast here so
really close to Sinclair uh type of
guitar to learn new transformation of
your space so that in this new space you
can do okay nearest neighbor or k-means
in a better way and the goal was really
to have a nice metric space you know and
because of this you need contrastive
style learning and on the opposite you
add yarn that was trying with xiaomi's
networks to learn representation close
to each other for inputs that are in the
same with the same class labels
basically or thematically correlated and
basically it was non-contractive just
trying to match the representation from
you know CMS type model and this was
also something else ago right this was
for like a fraud signature fraud
detection and so this emerged like 30
years ago and you have those two big Sea
Lord let's say viewed that continue to
improve improve until what we have today
so it's really nice to see the evolution
basically and I would say so this was
maybe the origin of this whole path in
between you had let's say uh increase of
spectral embedding with kernel method at
one point you know maybe at the end of
the 90s 2000 and this is where you had
LaPlace
all those things right and then after
this now you have again the rise of SSL
where they said okay let's remove the
kernel method let's instead use deep net
as a filterizer but still the same sort
of criteria right which means what we
show in the poster and now you get those
really nice you know regime where you
can actually extrapolate and it's also
efficient for large data set and so on
so it's really nice to see the
simulations through the last three
decades absolutely and um I was reading
uh on on you know Yan's take of um uh
contrasted versus non-contractive in his
recent autonomous AI paper and he was
describing the benefits and his view of
non-contrasted methods is kind of shrink
wrapping the the latent representation
and you had a bit of a spicy take
yesterday where you're saying you're now
slightly more skeptical about the the um
the need for that yeah so I think it
really depends on the situation that you
are in and that's one of the guidelines
that we try to to show in this paper uh
basically you have some properties that
will represent with contrastive and some
other with non-contractive and depending
in the situation you are in you may want
to use one or the other but there are
cases where actually the representation
will coincide between those two so it's
not a white and black story it's really
uh the you have like a spectrum let's
say and in some regime it does not
matter which method you use you will
learn the same representation in some
other cases you might prefer one from
the other and this type of question you
can only answer read theoretically
because you cannot do huge scale
experiment of thousands of data sets
thousands of architecture and so on and
this is what we try to do in this paper
amazing amazing well um we're here at
Europe's today and um this is the uh the
kind of the boobs area where a lot of
companies can demonstrate what they're
working on then
um you're going to be doing a poster
session next door yes yes this afternoon
yeah yeah for tomorrow and the next day
so feel free to come by uh yeah I mean
it's actually insane Randall's got so
many papers that he's presented that
that's really low care but it's really
easy when you have yarn you're not
throwing up so much idea nearby so you
just have to pick up on them and
basically walk them out so I I cheat a
little bit on that spot you know
brilliant well we're on day two of the
conference I mean do you have any any
thoughts on on what you've experienced
so far uh so far I think the
organization is pretty smooth and the
posters all is really well organized we
can walk around and figure out which
paper are interesting uh you just have
to be passionate to be in the queue for
food basically that's the only the
downside and also if you like both we
have a lot of work both advertisements
somehow nearby so this is a bit
intriguing as well you know yeah but
accept that no I think everything is
going great and a lot of people are I
think really happy to be here I met a
lot of people who don't really have any
paper or submission but still are able
to come and I think everyone is excited
four minutes the first in-person
conference is complete so yeah I think
everyone is really cheerful and happy to
share their reserves so so far it's
really nice yeah all right nice to see
you give us the elevator here right so
this is paper primarily done with
Randall and Ian and in this work we
really study the effect of data
augmentation and how it can basically
affect the models parameters and a loss
function now typically when people do
this there is no real understanding of
how data augmentation affects this loss
apart from really just like sitting and
training this and you can think of this
as a Monte Carlo estimator where you're
actually drawing samples from this
distribution of data augmentation and
you're trying trying to figure out how
it affects the loss function or the
model this is one of the first Works to
actually show an analytical closed form
way of studying the effect of data
augmentation on model parameters and to
the best of our knowledge it's one of
the first works also to do this for a
wide range of data augmentations
practically used in computer vision like
color data gaussing blur fine transforms
and what we actually show is that you
can think of all transforms as an
operator on top of the image we compute
the expected image the variance image it
leads to like pretty cool visualizations
also understanding why data augmentation
makes the model focus on Textures or
edges and then finally we show a close
form of date of models when using a
certain family data augmentations so
yeah that's it how are you find in the
conference the conference has been good
it's actually been really diverse
compared to like I'm used to attending
cvpr so this is one of the conferences
where I actually get to see lots of
other ideas lots of other fields and
it's been really fun amazing it's safe
such an honor to meet you in person is
without a doubt one of the world's
leading experts in division so it means
so much to me to me in person